hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday December 12 2016 what's going on
how why yeah
I've got to be a little quiet man it's
only like 6:30 in the morning out here
my lovely wife is still sleeping and so
I'm trying not to wake her up from
upstairs gonna try to be a good boy this
[ __ ] week all right I'm still gonna
say all the fucked-up [ __ ] I always say
I'm just gonna say it at a volume it's
you know a little more palpable for
college on sounds of slamming you know I
woke up this morning bah buh buh buh I
heard this big [ __ ] booming noise and
you ever get that feeling like you're
like that I just dream that or somebody
in the house right and then you
immediately start thinking like all
right I got kitchen knives I got a
[ __ ] softball bat right next to my
bed and but the reality is you know as
much as people are I want gun control
and all of that [ __ ] I mean that's the
first thing you think of you know you
know there should be a [ __ ] thing
right where if you look if they can
[ __ ] test you one goddamn time yeah
so like five [ __ ] questions then all
of a sudden you never have to go through
any sort of [ __ ] you know major
security at the airport because one time
you didn't act like a [ __ ] lunatic
and then I guess you're good for the
rest of your life why can't just like
one time they can't come up with the
same type of a test whatever the [ __ ]
they're sitting down at the airport they
can't come up with that for [ __ ]
regular people you know you know be
perfect just have a [ __ ] 38 and they
let you have a silencer
now [ __ ] that a Glock with the silencer
because you don't want to ruin your ears
you just want to kill the person that
comes in your house right it'd be great
be right there next to your table and
the person comes walking in you know
give me your [ __ ] money just reach
over to they [ __ ] hit the ground you
put the gun back down you just go back
to sleep and you know a couple hours
wait back up again you like I always say
your brother lock him up
oh that's right that's right honey yeah
while you were sleeping here's some guy
broken yeah she's dead
you want to uh you want to call the cops
I'll get some you know get the coffee
going you know everybody you know they
tell you don't have a knife or anything
like that you want bat we'll give you
distance but at the end of the day you
know what I mean
there has to be some sort of test they
look at your [ __ ] driving record
right how you did in high school Jesus
I'd be out the window I don't know what
the for the [ __ ] they do it okay and you
know you just get you got a you get a
Glock with a [ __ ] silencer you don't
hurt your ears you know the aim center
mass or whatever be it would be a great
[ __ ] thing I really think would be a
great thing you know as long as you knew
what everybody's feet sounded like on
the floor in your house as long as you
know what you knew what their walk
sounded like that would be the test
right there all your loved ones in your
house they would from bare feet to
[ __ ] snow shoes you just had to be
like alright that's my son Mikey okay
that's my wife and she's wearing Uggs
right he get it all down right so then
you know what the [ __ ] sound is I
don't know I'm just saying I had a
little [ __ ] her in a noise I get a
little nervous so I was just like what
am i Jason [ __ ] born over here I'm
not you know my wife's been snoring to
beat the [ __ ] bad now that she's in
the third trimester which is
understandable the kids laying on her
[ __ ] lungs so I have to go upstairs
to sleep and all of this [ __ ] went
through my [ __ ] head all right like
what if somebody came in downstairs took
out my wife and left with no [ __ ]
fingerprints they're gonna [ __ ] blame
me that's the first thing I thought not
oh my god my pregnant wife was gonna be
dead first thing I thought is I'm gonna
go to jail for that [ __ ]
that's what you know I'm really selfish
when I'm in the middle of the night I'm
really groggy like like right now I'm
awake and I'd be like well I would be
too
I would give a [ __ ] what they did to me
at that point I would be so upset that I
lost my wife but when I'm laying
nice and toasty under the sheets that's
the first thing I thought of like man I
love this bed now I wouldn't have this
bed in jail anyways we'll get down to it
people there's only another [ __ ] 19
days left in this year dude [ __ ]
Christmas by the way [ __ ] Christmas
right up the old [ __ ] yahoo all right
- [ __ ] that stupid ass [ __ ] holiday
it's for [ __ ] kids the level of
[ __ ] pressure I have to run around it
by [ __ ] adults [ __ ] presents what
do you want to shoot you train you
[ __ ] [ __ ] I don't have time for this
[ __ ] I got too much other stuff to do it
Benedict it day yeah it's [ __ ] brutal
man I had one of the worst one of the
worst [ __ ] I wasn't gonna talk about
this I had one of the worst [ __ ]
weeks of my life and this Christmas
music in the background is [ __ ]
driving me nuts I'm gonna gloss over all
of this [ __ ] cuz I've never gotten
emotional on the podcast I do not want
to do it now you know I told you one of
my good friends died I went to the
memorial service and you know is - you
know he's got two kids ten years old
went up and spoke at it was the most
heart-wrenching thing I ever saw and
then Thursday I know this is gonna be
probably devastating to a lot of you
guys I had to give my dog away yes
no Cleo I had to do it I got a baby
coming and the Cleo that you hear on the
podcast is not the Cleo that
[Music]
unfortunately when anybody else comes to
the door and you know she tried to
attack my parents my brother-in-law my
father-in-law all of my friends she bit
one of my friends nipped him and was
just like it you know it was a ticking
[ __ ] time bond for seven years with
the dog I love the dog to death my wife
loves the dog I was [ __ ] devastates
the most devastating thing I've had to
do it's just one of those adult
decisions where it was like my brain was
like there's no [ __ ]
way you can have a baby crawling around
that then becomes a toddler and they
don't know how to [ __ ] pet a dog and
then she gets little older and then has
friends over and their parents come over
it was just a it was a ticking time bomb
she does not do well adjusting to new
things and something horrible was gonna
happen and then she was going to get put
down so I had to do the responsible
thing and found her a great home and
this is what kills me is she's totally
adjusted now and his [ __ ] happy as
[ __ ] and I'm [ __ ] devastated because
she's a [ __ ] dog and within four days
they're like oh it's just a new deal
you're the guy now all right so I'll
tell you a quick story dude [ __ ] I
had to hand the dog off to my trainer
right so the whole morning I don't want
to act emotional because I don't want
the dog to be nervous and so I took her
on one last hike it's [ __ ] brutal and
then I was gathering up all her stuff I
give it all to the trainer and I go to
hand off the [ __ ] dog and it's like I
didn't want her to be nervous so I
barely even said goodbye I was like all
right buddy okay see you later because I
didn't want it to be nervous because I
loved it so much and then I [ __ ] you
know you know the trainer takes it and
then I went back in the house went to
the bathroom and then [ __ ] cried like
a little boy [ __ ] brutal brutal you
know it's [ __ ] hilarious
by the way women handle this [ __ ]
emotion like my wife like sobbed like
five or six [ __ ] times including the
night before and then they'd their
ability to [ __ ] move ahead is is
[ __ ] astounding like they can they
can know it's sad deal with it being sad
they [ __ ] cry it out of them and then
I'm not saying she's not heartbroken
she's [ __ ] devastated but like their
ability their [ __ ] ability
the handle [ __ ] like that versus a guy
guys [ __ ] deny deny deny and then
they just hold on to the [ __ ] you know
what I mean buddy of theirs you know
what I mean they're married they got a
couple of kids but you get like two
three scotches in them they talk start
talking about some broad from [ __ ] 25
years ago it's like dude what are you
gonna let it go we cuz you know we're
not allowed like when I cried over my
dog the whole time I was fighting it so
it was like an eight-second cry boohoo
done alright fight it off her just keep
it right there in your chest keep it
[ __ ] right there and then you know
I'm telling you [ __ ] like nine years
from now being a [ __ ] Christmas party
and have a couple too many [ __ ]
Zinfandels and I'll lash out at somebody
and they'll be a dude where the [ __ ] did
that come from and it's and I'm not even
gonna know it's gonna be because I
didn't hug my dog before I mean I
definitely you know I did with the days
coming up on that type of [ __ ] but I
should have given it one last [ __ ]
hug but I knew I couldn't do it you know
so alright let's pass that let's get
past that anyways so I went to the Rams
game yesterday by the way I did hit
pause to regroup brutal brutal [ __ ]
brotherly and the whole [ __ ] time I
got a city of listen to [ __ ]
Christmas music everywhere I go you know
if I had a hammer I am or is that a
[ __ ] Christmas song it's kind of a
[ __ ] psycho song right second adult
says I had a hammer we all know what a
hammers for two all right
I always get nervous when I hear that
first sentence if I had a hammer anyway
so I went to the Rams verse that Lana
Falcons game yesterday buddy of mine had
tickets and I was like dude I gotta go
cuz I really wanted to see the Los
Angeles Rams playing in the LA Memorial
Coliseum I mean that's where all the
greats played from the Rams history
right
I believe Eric Dickerson played there
before he went to before they move down
to Anaheim probably the last of the
greats to play there
the fearsome foursome right Lamar Lamar
Lundy Merlin Olsen rosey Grier Deacon
Jones no one else Roman Gabriel that was
all before my time then I came in when
it was the [ __ ] quarterback
controversy of Pat Haden Vince Ferragamo
Wendell Tyler right Jim and Jack
Youngblood what was crazy about them is
back then if somebody had the same
always if somebody has the same last
name as you they put just your first
initial than a period but it was Jack
and Jim so they had to write their whole
names and said Jack Youngblood on the
back it never looked right
it looked [ __ ] weird but anyways I
went there and it was the typical LA
sporting experience that you a lot of
times where there's just as many fans if
not more fans because it's a transient
city it really has nothing to do with LA
fans there's just so many people like
myself that moved out here you know
chasing the old Hollywood dream or if
people had just [ __ ] sick of you know
just bad weather people are just always
[ __ ] moving it by the way dude I'm
telling you right now dude this [ __ ]
real-estate bubble out here I've been
building all of these [ __ ] luxury
apartment buildings you know where I
[ __ ] go over and play hockey the
bigot this thing that The Pickwick
hockey thing that's also a bowling alley
in a function room they [ __ ] knocking
that whole thing down knocking that
whole [ __ ] thing down because they're
gonna have luxury apartments it's just
there's gonna be no place to skate out
here the one that was over and [ __ ]
was at Century City or some [ __ ] get
confused over there begins with the
scene ain't cut I don't know what it is
they [ __ ] that one's done now this
one's gone the only one the ones I know
those went down by the airport and
there's one over noon like there's
Sherman Oaks Valley Ice Center and other
than that I know I left the [ __ ] go
buy some rollerblades right there's a
little [ __ ] short shorts do that
stupid thing you know we set up the
cones and you
come up to them and turn around
backwards right anyways yeah dude so
they have so they had this this [ __ ] in
one building right and a really
impressive building it's over near
Beverly Hills so I was just like I and
I'll see what that build is about I go
on the internet right it's called the
ten thousand I'm like alright why is it
called the ten thought it's called the
ten thousand
because that's the amount of month money
you have to pay a month to live there
because bare minimum
how [ __ ] tackies like how many times
are we gonna [ __ ] do this you know
what I mean it's like we always actually
as always like some sort of like crash
and everybody [ __ ] loses everything
by everybody I mean the [ __ ] lower
99% gets their [ __ ] asses kicked and
then you know give it a couple years and
all of a sudden it just comes right back
out go around again to the bud Fox greed
is good dude how [ __ ] tacky is that
the name of the building is the minimal
this is how much you're paying and rent
Jesus Christ have a little bit of
[ __ ] class yeah they're just
everywhere they're putting up luxury
apartments I don't know where the [ __ ]
they gonna find all these people to to
fill these things but I guarantee you
they're not gonna do it like I was
thinking of buying a small apartment
building out here but everybody's
[ __ ] buying them up I can't even
afford to [ __ ] get in one or you know
just because it's stupid it's like at
the height of the [ __ ] market you
know I was thinking of buying like a
parking garage or some [ __ ] just a
parking lot you know [ __ ] all these
people gonna park it said building
parking underneath the goddamn things
and I think at it all figured out you
know I guess I'll be telling jokes for
the rest of my [ __ ] life I'm trying
to have some sort of something a
lemonade stand or something where I get
into my older [ __ ] years I got some
sort of loot coming in that doesn't have
to do with me [ __ ] putting on my
tap-dancing shoes
I don't know so anyways I went to the
the Los Angeles Rams game yesterday and
it was so great to see them play there
even though they had
[ __ ] brutal game they were down 42 to
nothing - Madi ice and [ __ ] [ __ ]
the Rams and I mean the Falcons and
evidently their best receiver whoever
the [ __ ] that is Julio Jones or some
[ __ ] I think I heard that name is that a
baseball player I don't know I don't
play fantasy sports and I'm too [ __ ]
busy to really pay attention as much as
I used to
he wasn't even playing and they just
kicked the [ __ ] out him you know it's
funny the rams finally scored a
touchdown right to make it 42 to 7 and
they lit the Olympic torch I'm sure they
just light it late at night but it
seemed like that's when I first noticed
that it was on and then they also had a
fumble recovery for a touchdown the
crowds going nuts so whatever that
happens live the first thing I do is try
to pick up a referee to see if I see you
know him goin oh no no no no it's it's a
dead ball or if he's saying touchdown
and as the guy was crossing the goal
line you can see the ref was already
going no no no pointing at the ground
saying it was you know neither the guy
was down or whatever right and the
[ __ ] fireworks guy the [ __ ]
fireworks guy shoots the fireworks off
on a touchdown that got called back it's
[ __ ] hilarious because they're not
selling out games you know that probably
I bet that guy got chewed out [ __ ] an
owner probably came down as camel-hair
coat you know where the [ __ ] is a gun at
fireworks guy
I'm sorry mr. mr. [ __ ] owner I shut
the [ __ ] up it's coming out of your pay
he's down there [ __ ] crying
but it was such a great stadium it holds
90,000 people for the life of me can
somebody explain to me why the Los
Angeles Rams need a new football stadium
there's a football stadium there's two
of them there's the Rose Bowl and
there's the [ __ ] LA Memorial Coliseum
why do we have to take more [ __ ]
natural resources out of the [ __ ]
earth to build another one of these
stupid-ass [ __ ] stadiums that's are
they gonna have luxury boxes and put all
the bells and whistles on it you know so
they can attract people who aren't into
sports to go to the [ __ ] event
I love that [ __ ] Stadium I had a
great time I love that it's a so-called
[ __ ] I think it's great
do you know there was 62 steps to get
from [ __ ] where I was seating sitting
back up to the main concourse to [ __ ]
walk out of the stadium
it's [ __ ] tremendous 62 steps you
know it makes you drink less you burn in
a bunch of calories there's less fat
[ __ ] but now what do they say oh that's
a fire hazard the inclines too steep and
we're [ __ ] and we're so soft in this
[ __ ] country that's why I like
everybody's trying to get me all freaked
out about having a kid about how
difficult it's going to be and I'm not
saying it's not gonna be difficult but
it's like people women used to have kids
and then they'd [ __ ] die and then the
[ __ ] guy had to go out bury his wife
and get behind a team of oxen plow some
rocky goddamn field and then [ __ ] I
don't know feed the kid
I don't goat's milk at that point I have
no idea and somehow he did it you know
people have survived plagues I can't
[ __ ] be in a house with central air
conditioning and heat and all of this
[ __ ] I you know I mean how much [ __ ]
harder is oh god I wish parents from
[ __ ] in the past could come and
listen to the way people [ __ ] wine
and go on and on about themselves you
know and the way they lecture people who
don't have kids dude you have no idea my
god it's so shut the [ __ ] up
these [ __ ] people coming over you
know come paddle it over from Cuba on a
[ __ ] refrigerator door fighting off
sharks you know you can't hate you can't
change a couple of diapers I'm telling
you people are [ __ ] their [ __ ] the
[ __ ] soft people are [ __ ] soft
they they [ __ ] [ __ ] moan and
complain yes yes there's things in life
you know I'd say at this point with all
the modern gadgets alright if you have a
job if you're not worried about money as
far as you have enough [ __ ] money to
make your rent in all that stuff I mean
a kid shouldn't be any more difficult
considering the love
that you're gonna get other than you
know a major [ __ ] adjustment and
something that's inconvenient but I mean
come on it's difficult yeah compared to
the rest and compared to what sit down
and playing PlayStation at [ __ ] 38
years of age I might eat these words but
I mean I'm just comparing it to the fact
that you know these people used to live
in the [ __ ] middle of nowhere they'd
have like 14 [ __ ] kids I can't handle
one I got all the sports packages right
I mean what well I mean how my [ __ ]
life's a joke literally
anyways I I don't know let's go let's
try to stay on topic I have no [ __ ]
idea why they need a new stadium it's
it's you know I can't talk and type in
my password come on
mistake what did Bill focus da when he
does it anyway so we went to the game
and I had a great time and [ __ ]
Atlanta fans will like just the amount
of [ __ ] talking dude there was this one
guy this one [ __ ] guy he bought those
[ __ ] wide receiver gloves you know
where they have the logo of the team and
then they crossed the hands and they put
their hands up over the heads you know
like wouldn't like the [ __ ] franchise
player scores a touchdown he does that
and it looks cool he was doing that at
the end of the game just holding his
hands up facing facing the [ __ ] Rams
fans I'm telling you dude this guy was
like 50 all right you know all wired
then you know Street dude right 50 years
old it he walked out and he was making
doing his selfie video as he walked out
you know talking all this [ __ ] it's like
dude you beat the [ __ ] ramps I mean
let's [ __ ] relax you're not beating
the Giants you're not beating Seattle
you're not beating the Cowboys you're
not doing [ __ ] this year [ __ ] guy
running out like they just won a playoff
game I don't know what it is about me
but I [ __ ] hate when the fans from
the visiting team take over a stadium
even if I don't give a [ __ ] about the
team
I respect the ramp so next thing you
know I'm talking all this [ __ ] to Rams
fan I mean to Falcons fans in the back
of my head I'm like why are you doing
this bill you don't give a [ __ ] it's
just a Rams fans they didn't have
anything they weren't coming with the
[ __ ] talk better they couldn't they have
down 42 7 right
42 14 I think was the final so at one
point you know when they went up 42 to
nothing all these Falcons fans they
start chanting ATL ATL ATL and I just
started yelling you're a Hub City no one
goes to Atlanta we passed through your
city on to our final destination started
yelling all this [ __ ] about Delta
Airlines I believe that that's the hub
there and afterwards I just started
thinking why do I care
oh and I also screamed that the [ __ ]
Atlanta's punter he [ __ ] punted the
ball and this guy had a nice run back
and he get comes off the field now
granted he could have been mad that he
kicked it to the wrong guy or he's
supposed to kick it away but he came off
the field and he did the double [ __ ]
pulling the chin straps off and he was
like [ __ ] screaming all this [ __ ] he was
all upset I [ __ ] went off on him I
didn't remember what the [ __ ] I said I
was just so beside myself that a punter
would talk that level it's like just sit
the [ __ ] down if they watched your
uniform once this year [ __ ] dope
you're closer to sitting in the stands
than you are actually being on that [ __ ]
it do you know I mean you don't be like
it'd be like if this guy was in the army
and he's he like peels potatoes and he's
talking [ __ ] cuz he cut his finger or
something like that and meanwhile he's
sitting around a bunch of people that
just came back from the front lines
that's how I look at it I mean I might
be a [ __ ] I have no idea so anyways when
I was sitting there watching the Rams
game I mentioned to my buddy that uh
there used to be a football stadium I
couldn't remember the name of it I first
I said the Baker Bowl and I was like I
think that might be in Philly but there
was a there was a stadium for anybody
who lives out here
la lot of people you know la is really
bad about their history and they had a
stadium that was down where the farmers
market is on Fairfax and Beverly it's
actually a baseball stadium there too I
don't know anything about that but they
had a stadium called the Gilmore stadium
and called Gilmore Stadium and they had
a couple of NFL like all-star games
there and then they had like some
defunct football league like the LA
Bulldogs or some [ __ ] played there and
looked it up on Wikipedia really this
morning I couldn't uh couldn't sleep
that well old heartbroken Billy here
couldn't sleep last night and then the
baseball field that was next to it if
you ever watched those classic home run
derbies will they have like Al Kaline
vs. like Mickey Mantle and [ __ ] and you
know they're in LA and you're like where
the [ __ ] is that Stadium they filmed a
lot of it at the stadium right next to
it right now there's like the CBS lot
there where they film like the price is
right and [ __ ] and as I was looking that
up I didn't know this they actually had
a Wrigley Field in LA that looks like
from the map it was near or north of
Watts
LA which is south of the 10 in east of
the 110 and it was built by the same guy
that made Wrigley Field in Chicago and
komisky Field I'm a [ __ ] nerd I like
looking up that [ __ ] I looked up [ __ ]
about the Rams they've won one Super
Bowl they wanted in st. Louis obviously
1999 people went remember that and they
won an NFL title in 1945 when they were
still in Cleveland which is where they
started so they've never won an NFL
title or a [ __ ] Super Bowl here in LA
and I got to tell you after watching him
yesterday they don't seem like they're
that much closer [ __ ] Jeff Fisher
taking all kinds of [ __ ] all kinds of
[ __ ] they need to fire them they need to
fire his ass all right well we think who
else is we gonna replace him with you
gotta have a replacement I mean this
guy's been in the [ __ ] league forever
did take a team to the Super Bowl
however it was [ __ ] 17 years ago he
did well with Vince Young
you know but in defense of him you know
if you looked at the less since the
Patriots started going to the Super Bowl
okay the Patriots have gone to six
[ __ ] Super Bowls all right and then
as far as winning Patriots have won four
Steelers won two Giants won two Packers
won why me it's like literally like
every [ __ ] decade there's like two or
three teams that just [ __ ] run the
table in the [ __ ] 90s it was a
Cowboys won three Broncos won two
there's half the Super Bowls the [ __ ]
gone right there and you knew the 49ers
we're gonna get one and they went for
the previous decade there's just always
that Steelers won four and let's look at
the 80s the 80s it was 49ers one for the
Raiders one to that's six gone right
there Giants won one Redskins won one
Redskins won - all right so that's four
- and - you got three teams that won
eight of the ten and then it was the
Bears you know whoever the [ __ ] else I
just said I can't remember one the other
one wait a minute how's it go it goes
Raiders 49ers Redskins Raiders 49ers
Bears Giants Redskins 49ers 49ers Oh
giant sea islands Giants and bears one
one all right sorry I'm getting all
[ __ ] nerded out here with the with
the [ __ ] Sports Talk here which I'll
probably do a little bit more of but uh
I probably should do some advertising
here but I want to talk to you guys
about some [ __ ] where um I told you I've
been starting to get I found someone you
know I [ __ ] up my backlash star this
year with the sciatic nerve thinks I am
right I went through all of that [ __ ]
through that I found a great
chiropractor and then a great masseuse
which has led me to this other person
that I just went to who's you know a
former like mr. universe bodybuilder and
all that he's a [ __ ] genius and
everything in
I went to go see this guy because I
[ __ ] up my rotator cuff
like years ago I've been trying to just
fight through it and all that type of
[ __ ] and I finally went to go see this
guy and like I came walking in and you
know those bodybuilders they spend their
lives just looking in the mirror you
know with [ __ ] clothes on he just saw
all of my [ __ ] it was it he just went
like I your shoulders are rotated
forward your left one is actually closer
to your neck than your right one is and
then he go and he goes stand in the
mirror you see that dude I brush my
teeth every [ __ ] twice a day right
two three times a [ __ ] day I've never
noticed that Mike holy [ __ ] he's right
because it's rotated in and turned ever
so slightly it's not like it's like
[ __ ] three inches but you really have
to look at it and then he goes all right
do me a favor turn your head to the left
and turn it to the right and then he
just started smiling cuz he knew what my
[ __ ] issue was whatever you that neck
muscle is my chest and my trap muscles
are too [ __ ] tight and you trap easy
muscle whatever is it goes all the way
down to the middle of your back but mine
is super tight up top and my chest is
tight so it's pulling everything forward
and it's making my shoulders go up like
my shoulders always go up like so he
gave me this [ __ ] stretch even if you
don't have this [ __ ] problem I got a
tell hopefully I can describe it over
the podcast here it's just stand up
straight right and then just lift your
chest up put your shoulders back put
your [ __ ] shoulders back lift your
chest up like - like you feel like
you're trying to make it go to the
ceiling and then have your hands your
arms bring your arms back behind you
palms up and stretch back as far as you
can alright like you're totally open it
up your chest as you bring your arms
back and try to hold that for a minute
it's been a complete game-changer now so
like my shoulders have come back because
I don't want to masseuse she beat the
[ __ ] out of my neck and my shoulders are
[ __ ] down a little bit more but like
I swear - got it what I used to do like
yoga stretches like on one
I could totally like you know they
always like reach around and grab your
arm or whatever that yoga [ __ ] I could
totally do it on one side could not do
it on the other side and that for my
whole life like I've had this [ __ ]
problem like one shoulder being higher
than the other forever you know it's
some nurse when I was in high school
goes oh you got a little bit of
scoliosis yeah your spines a little
curved and blah blah blah blah blah and
like and this [ __ ] who I don't know
what the [ __ ] she was I was just like
yeah that's the problem and it wasn't so
I talked to this guy he was just going
like oh yeah I'll have you [ __ ]
straightened out in like a month or
something and so he gave me these
exercises to strengthen up the lower
part of the trap easy whatever and for
the first time in my life I'm gonna be
actually be able to sit up straight just
naturally and do it the amount of [ __ ]
that it is affected it's given me back
problems like playing drums and stuff
like I for ever having to like a just
[ __ ] and wondering why one like I sit
down like why I have to bring the snare
higher than I should have to bring it
you know and everybody else would just
sit down at me now it seems pretty
normal to me I had no [ __ ] idea what
the deal was that evidently I was all
crooked up top so I got to tell you
that's something that I've learned this
year where the biggest things I've
learned this year is like how medicine
if you go to a shoulder doctor he's just
gonna [ __ ] look at your shoulder you
don't mean you got to get backed off
he's just looking at you [ __ ] back
but you got at least these masseuses and
people like that they understand how the
whole [ __ ] body works and they
understand like oh this is pulled out of
alignment in it always comes down to
balance where it's like these muscles
are too tight and the muscles on the
other side are two weeks so this is
either pulling this forward or pulling
this back which is causing you to
compensate when you walk and that's Nick
you literally have a problem with you
your left foot because of your right
shoulder it's [ __ ] amazing if you get
a good one
all right you go to some rug and rub and
tug place you're still gonna have a
crooked back but oh you're gonna walk
out with this
on your face sorry all right
I know I haven't been this too funny
alright I'm going through a lot of [ __ ]
here all right let me let me read the
let me read the the advertising here for
this week okay oh jesus here we go
Dollar Shave Club everybody Dollar Shave
Club delivers amazing affordable raises
right to your door every month so you
can get a great shape but raises aren't
the only thing you need in the bathroom
what about all the shower stuff turns
out Dollar Shave Club thought of that
too you know what the reality is all you
need is shampoo shampoo still soap if
you wash yourself with shampoo all these
different types of [ __ ] you know well
how did you decided you bathe back in
the day you sat in a [ __ ] tub you
know they didn't have any soap did they
and like kill a [ __ ] go to some [ __ ]
I don't know I turn the grease and just
a bar of soap how often would you do I
don't [ __ ] know you jumped in a river
they just came out with a new line of
shower products shampoo and body wash
shampoo and body wash called the
wanderer I love this shampoo and body
wash and one perfect the fragrances are
unlike anything on the market this
subtle and actually smell like real
natural ingredients there are a lot of
body washes out there that make you
smell like a teenager I don't know what
a teenager smells like and I think
that's a good thing it keeps me off a
lot of watch lists list of lists this
mint and cedarwood body wash is amazing
it makes you smell incredible evidently
that is all one flavor somebody sent it
to me you got to give it a try once
you're in the club you'll see the
products work amazing the service is
world-class there's no long term
commitments no hidden fees and you can
cancel whenever you want and best of all
they're giving away a one-month trial of
any of their razors for a dollar with
free shipping and after that it's just a
few bucks get your $1 trial at
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's Darla's
shave club.com / / okay oh Jesus oh
Jesus if you don't like Christmas
shopping okay if you're wondering why
you have to buy
another full-grown [ __ ] adult goddamn
you know you know whatever a fire engine
or some [ __ ] if you just like to get it
done here's the thing you do right here
just get him some Sherry's berries
man a woman you get it a woman they can
appreciate it maybe they'll even [ __ ]
you who knows what they're thinking I
don't pretend to know all right you get
it for a guy it's [ __ ] hilarious
getting your guy friend
chocolate-covered strawberries I
challenge you get for funny or [ __ ]
that's funny
there you go sweetie I love you take
this two sherries berries take the
stress out of shopping queue Sherry's
berries instead tis the season of
[ __ ] sharing follow la la la la la la
la this is the copy known as I just said
tis the season of sharing and shopping
no matter who you're shopping for
Sherry's berries it's the one-stop shop
for everyone on your list can you
believe I blew out my voice defending
the Los Angeles Rams while playing the
Atlanta Falcons when the [ __ ] do I give
a [ __ ] about the NFC West no matter who
you're shopping for Sherry's berries is
the one-stop shop for everyone on your
list you don't have to battle the crowds
to get the perfect gift shop with
convenience right from your home tell a
personal story go [ __ ] yourself it's
chocolate want strawberries it's America
eat it and enjoy it the scripture words
for berries decadent fresh juicy let's
just get to the [ __ ] here with Christmas
right around the corner there's only one
way to get these amazing 1999 Sherry's
Berry's deal and help support our show
just visit Berry's dot-com berr IES comm
click on the microphone in the top right
hand corner and type in bur Sherry's
berries has something for everyone
and every taste go to berries comm click
on the microphone type in per order them
today all right what do we got left
we got three left so let's get over the
hump and we'll do this real quick tipsy
elves everybody you know what I saw some
middle-aged white lady with the wu-tang
clan Christmas sweater I think that sets
the bar
it was the classic Christmas sweater
pattern with the wu-tang W on the front
and it was black and yellow right didn't
they used to say killer bees or some
[ __ ] like that I don't know
alright tipsy elves everyone needs an
ugly Christmas sweater this time of year
if you want bragging rights for the most
talked about sweater your Christmas
party listen up talk talk about your
tipsy elves sweater and other products
you saw on their website well you know
what I didn't look at them you know what
you know I'm gonna do that this week
I'll do that this week what the [ __ ]
here we go tipsy elves so I can talk
about your [ __ ] sweaters tipsy elves
here we go what do they got now Jesus
Christ those things are [ __ ] hideous
they got Jesus Christ like it's a baby
but he still has the beard and one of
those things one of those things you
know you carry a baby and around front a
satchel you know they got Santa Claus on
a unicorn yeah this is ugly [ __ ] man's
Christmas suits
I guess that's if you want to get on TV
at a sporting event oh my god dude I
can't even [ __ ] read what does it say
belt digger I thought it said the n-word
that's when I first thought it sucked
and then I thought I'd said gold digger
hey you know what when I get off this
site you miss you drink birthday boy and
it's got Jesus Christ all right you know
what these people went they got the most
[ __ ] up looking [ __ ] I've ever seen
everyone needs another whatever tipsy
elves has hundreds of Christmas what I
just talked about this [ __ ] you get what
they are you know what they are how do
you get them right now my listeners get
20% off tipsy elves at tipsy elves calm
tipsy spelled TI psy you might have said
it you might have been called it but did
you ever have to spell it tipsy TI psy
elves calm on anything they order the
site go to tipsy elves calm enter my
code BER at checkout and get 20% off you
site-wide discount everything he gets
20% off that's tipsy elves calm
and your code Berg you know you got a
bunch of Christmas parties coming up and
if you wear that sweater and you get
[ __ ] up I mean it makes it even
funnier no one's gonna get upset right
anyways I've been hanging with my wife
you know barely doing any stand-up just
sitting there waiting for the kid to
come and poor thing she's all really
uncomfortable she's at the point she
spent such a trooper she's at the point
now she's just like let's get this kid
out of me right and last night was the
first time I saw it kick through this
[ __ ] and kick like I do these exercises
you know I have to help me do these
exercises so she can try to stay limber
and I just saw like it was literally
like it was like a foot just [ __ ]
kick this side it was just like it's
insane it's insane that there's a
goddamn kid in there it's the most
amazing [ __ ] thing and also like yeah
just say to your wife like there's no
way for them to convey it to you it's
like what is it like to have a person in
you living inside of you it's like can
you watch alien now and just be like I
get it I totally [ __ ] get it um so
anyways I hung in with her one night
right and we watched Rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer then we watched
Frosty the Snowman as much as I could
watch you know I don't get into Frosty
the Snowman
it's too [ __ ] if that one just gives
me anxiety
you watch Rudolph the red-nosed reindeer
and it's slightly about racism and
acceptance you know what I mean his own
dad is ashamed of them and then he tells
them to [ __ ] off and then there's all
the misfit toys there's something going
on there that's like this theme about
racism and special needs kids
I don't really there's just so many
[ __ ] other things going on that it's
really [ __ ] sad and you watch it and
it's fifty years old and you realize so
much hasn't changed and then if you go
right into Frosty the [ __ ] Snowman
and then here's this adult that's gonna
get on a [ __ ] choo-choo train with
some little girls she doesn't tell her
parents she's [ __ ] leave leaving and
then there's the [ __ ] stress that
it's gonna melt I was just like you know
what you gotta shut I can't handle this
right I can't [ __ ] handle this is
giving me too much anxiety right
and so then we switched over and we
watched a little bit of Mary Poppins
which I haven't seen in a long time
but I get all of those movies confused
you know the supercalifragilistic
expialidocious at that one chitty-chitty
bang-bang it's always some [ __ ] old
guy rich guy whose wife died and now the
new hot piece of ass comes in and she
shows him how to [ __ ] loosen up you
know what I mean
that role has now been taken over by
african-americans right they come in and
they teach the uptight white dude how to
[ __ ] I don't know do the electric
slide I never watched those [ __ ]
movies you know but back in the day it
was it was a new [ __ ] like chick in
the guy's life but this one he was like
married but it was Dick Van Dyke you
know by singing chim chiminey chim
chiminey chim chim Giroux the life herb
of a [ __ ] sweeper that's what I want
to do right then either were all [ __ ]
happy as hell you know completely
romancing blue-collar work like rich
people are all [ __ ] miserable these
people who are just gonna die at 39
cooking miners lung or somehow dancing
around up on the roofs you know covered
in [ __ ] sort and I got through as
much as that as I could get through and
you know I bought a Christmas tree and I
did all the dishes I watched all of that
[ __ ] and like you know but the next
morning I was going to the Rams game so
everything that I did in the last 24
hours is just completely wiped out it's
[ __ ] unbelievable that's how it works
man that's how it [ __ ] works
so anyways oh here's something that I
did not mention as this is something you
have to do as a man especially if you
have a wife and a family you got to get
life insurance and I'm doing it this
[ __ ] week I just you know lost
another friend who didn't [ __ ] have
it and you just you have to [ __ ] do
it guys we don't like dealing with our
[ __ ] mortality I know you've watched
enough of the first 48 that you
literally given your wife a motivation
to [ __ ] take you out you know what I
mean but you got to do it you got to
[ __ ] do it so I'm doing that this
week just meant
brutal [ __ ] week this week I learned
about loss you know like I didn't
already have enough [ __ ] examples I
got the old [ __ ] right there Fred
this week anyways clown ahead how about
the [ __ ] Giants now [ __ ] amazing
other New York Football Giants every
[ __ ] year I've been saying it all
year
Eli Manning is bored in September in
October and then oh we got to [ __ ]
win some games here he just the guy just
comes to [ __ ] life
they beat the [ __ ] Cowboys again they
got this amazing [ __ ] defense this is
this is what I'm so jealous up as a
Patriots fan I don't [ __ ] get how I
was first for going like why do we
always have to get rid of our guys that
are getting becoming stars this year
Chandler Jones we got rid of and
what's-his-face we sent over to the
[ __ ] Browns you know always for the
same [ __ ] a [ __ ] second-round draft
pick you know we got rid of Chandler
Jones and when was he in the [ __ ] guys
name from [ __ ] Florida University
whatever I I'm sick guys I'm so [ __ ]
busy with my wife right now I don't know
who the [ __ ] you right now but it's
just what I hate about the [ __ ]
Patriots speaking of balance is we have
all our money on the offensive side of
the ball all our stars are on the
offensive [ __ ] side and we're forever
getting rid of these [ __ ] corner
backs why won't we pay a [ __ ] corner
back all the way back to Ty Law and
lawyer Milloy we just constantly get rid
of those [ __ ] guys you know you watch
well we'll get rid of that [ __ ] kid
who picked me that pick in the [ __ ]
Super Bowl against Seattle well [ __ ]
get rid of him when he wants a contract
I don't [ __ ] get it
Gronk Spade Brady's paid I'm at a
imagine Edelman's gonna get paid if he's
not paid already and then nobody on the
other side of the [ __ ] ball it seems
like whenever that whenever they do
whenever they [ __ ] defense wins [ __ ]
championships and we [ __ ] it forever
doing this you watch tonight how many
points is Tom Brady gonna have to put up
on the [ __ ] scoreboard to beat the
Ravens who always have a good defense I
[ __ ] love the Ravens I love the
Giants I love the Steelers I love those
[ __ ] teams that just they always have
a great [ __ ] defense what kills me
about the Giants is they got this
[ __ ] killer defense and they still
have Eli
they got [ __ ] what's-his-face there
you know Jesus Christ what a [ __ ]
diva he is even he's not on the field
he's got to be like you know trying to
get the crowd going like they're not
into the game I [ __ ] hate that [ __ ]
you know Adele Beckham it's like we get
it we get it you're a superstar it's not
enough that you had had a one-handed 90
yard [ __ ] catch now you got to be
sitting there [ __ ] up on the goddamn
say it stands there with the YMCA dance
with the [ __ ] crowd literally like
the defense is out there shutting down
the Dallas Cowboys and the [ __ ]
cameras on you because you're [ __ ]
doing Christmas carols with the [ __ ]
front section that drives me up the wall
right they got him they got they still
have enough money for that [ __ ] dude
Cruz it's it's amazing
but somehow Bill Belichick trades these
[ __ ] guys and gets like three or four
second-round draft picks that eventually
mature into these stars and then we win
a title and then it's like then they
want their money and then we [ __ ] get
rid of them again so believe it or not
as much as the Patriots are you know
looked upon as a number one or number
two seed may be behind the Raiders I
don't know I haven't watched the last
couple weeks I know the Broncos lost I
don't know how it [ __ ] works but you
got to think that we're one of the
favorites right to go to yet another
[ __ ] Super Bowl but this is actually
a rebuilding year for us that's how
great Bill Belichick is but I think the
Patriots lose tonight unless we got to
put up like I always say like 38 points
because Joe Flacco is no [ __ ] slouch
I don't know I just don't have any
[ __ ] faith in it and I don't think
that the Patriots defense stinks I just
think every [ __ ] year they're good
guys you know one or two guys it seems
gets the old [ __ ] heal oh you know
what the Patriots are really good we're
really good at finding that [ __ ]
white dude who fund
[ __ ] reason is [ __ ] really fast
the Wes Welker right the Edelman's the
Amendola sweet that's what the [ __ ] we
are good at and the Giants are great at
finding [ __ ] those guys that are
built like ours fast as a linebacker but
for some some some how are the size of a
defensive end they get all of those
[ __ ] guys they spot them a mile away
somehow we can't find them you know and
I think the Ravens and the Steelers they
they're really good at just getting
those Hall of Fame [ __ ] defensive
backs and linebackers Edie reads Ray
Lewis [ __ ] Steelers you can name like
50 goddamn [ __ ] people right from the
[ __ ] Steel Curtain all the way up to
Polamalu they just stayed I don't know
they just they just [ __ ] good at it
so I haven't said that I've been also
watching my Bruins I'm still trying to
see where we're working towards when we
sent the entire Stanley Cup winning team
gave you know over the course of
two-and-a-half seasons sent every
significant player from those teams out
the door except for Chara and Marshawn
and Bergy I don't know I don't see where
year and a half into this [ __ ] I don't
we're still a [ __ ] 8c this is right
where we were last year and I swear to
God if they make our coach take the fall
for this all right we better keep him
and at the end we fit we think that this
doesn't work out all right you
definitely keep cloack Julian you
definitely keep Cam Neely but Michael
Connells got a [ __ ] go because he's
the guy who me as far as I know he's the
guy that [ __ ] did all this I don't
know
you know the [ __ ] Bruins never want
to pay anybody I'm [ __ ] believable do
pasta knock a it's 18 [ __ ] goals
right I watched some of the Toronto game
yesterday I know we lost three to one I
don't know who scored I missed that part
and he's got 18 [ __ ] goals you
imagine if Seguin was there we would
have we have two [ __ ] lines at least
we admit we [ __ ] up when we got rid of
say him
whatever but you know something the
Celtics are looking good Al Horford is
the [ __ ] real deal and I think he's a
[ __ ] leader
I think he's got he's like a [ __ ]
superstar and he's not a [ __ ]
headcase I'm loving that guy you know we
got Isiah Thomas we got a point guard we
got a guy down low who actually can
[ __ ] pass the ball he's brought the
ball up the court as much as everybody's
freaking out about what had the Greek
freak there the Bucks is a bunch of guy
six foot 11 can do that I'm a [ __ ]
LeBron James he's been doing everything
that that guy does just because he
doesn't play the point guard position
everybody's [ __ ] freaking out but
that guy is amazing all right but uh I
don't know I'm loving what dannyandjess
is doing and I think we're one guy away
I don't know much about hoop whoever
that middle guy is between your number
one and your number five the power
forward I don't know what the [ __ ] we
need a tow with three I don't know what
the [ __ ] it is but if we could just have
another guy I bench we play great
[ __ ] defense and I bench is a little
suspect though right Kelly Olynyk comes
in and out of the [ __ ] guy who can't
I swear to God I I think I could
literally beat this guy taking foul
shots which one he's one like what was
it smart the guy with the [ __ ] blonde
hair anyway so let's uh let's get to
some of the questions here for this
[ __ ] week here I gotta wrap this up
too because the people have put me had
the punch list guys are coming back to
put the finishing touches on the kitchen
oh by the way you know this is free
advertising and a campfire cooktop top
grill you gotta get one dude I got one
in my backyard my wife was fighting me
on that thing I finally I shut her the F
up I went out and I made she steak and
cheese is one of her favorite [ __ ]
sandwiches I went out there I went on
the Internet I look for a simple [ __ ]
recipe all I did this season the meat
was a little Worcestershire sauce and
some salt that was it all right I had
white American cheese my wife isn't it
of peppers and onions I was like fine I
sauteed a little bit of mushrooms
I had these fresh French rolls to
[ __ ] game over game
she ate that thing she didn't have time
to say how great it was she just [ __ ]
wolf that thing down and I was leave
sitting there like you know I need the
approval mic was it good you Joyce she's
like how about the fact that I ate it in
a minute and I couldn't even talk
because my mouth was full so full that's
how good it was I was [ __ ] psyched I
haven't even done
I haven't even you can do Reubens on
that [ __ ] thing you can make the
whole grand Sam Slam breakfast hash
browns pancakes bacon the whole thing
get the bacon going slide the bacon over
you put the hashbrowns in that [ __ ]
grease go Jason law had already gave it
the nickname because I'm bringing it to
the room Rose Bowl he calls it the
game-changer and he's gonna be making
Reubens that day like he's literally JLo
head is a [ __ ] ridiculous
cook he's unbelievable right he's so
excited about that thing he'd like
dropped his voice like three octaves I
sent him a picture he was saying here I
go dude you guys see what I got for the
tailgate tailgate this year he goes I
really do what'd you get what you get
and I show it to me he's just like dude
dude you got a cooktop that's [ __ ]
limitless hi-yi you can do brought Giggy
who do Reuben she can do breakfast just
kidding rattle and all I just started
laughing because that thing is that
thing is a game-changer it's literally a
[ __ ] game changer he was I can't even
tell you the ideas that he cuz he told
me I should put out my own one he had
all these [ __ ] great ideas but I want
anybody to steal it I probably won't put
it out anyways but um so steak and
cheese is on the forget about on the
diet by the way I've done cardio every
day this month
alright eleven days in I got day twelve
here I'm telling you go through the
holidays just do a [ __ ] a half-hour
cardio every [ __ ] day alright and you
pick your spots we eat like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] ate like a [ __ ] yesterday and
then today you get right back on it you
know and that way you start the year you
know you're not a fat [ __ ] you don't got
that extra ten to fifteen you don't like
deal with that [ __ ] oh you know or
whatever
don't listen to me or listen to me okay
let's get to the emails for this week
all right mom worried about me traveling
dear Billy's scrotum head I know what
that's just [ __ ] mean for me and say
my girlfriend and I have been dating for
five years now and finally decided to
travel abroad together you taking you
broad abroad she is a seasoned traveler
but I have yet to have traveled
internationally well that's great she
knows what she's doing just follow her
lead we recently purchased tickets to
Greece to pop my cherry sellable slash
celebrate her birthday that's great I
just told my mom about the trip and a
few days later received a text from her
very worried about traveling to Greece
slash out of the country I'm 27 years
old
mom and scared of me getting you left
out some words there buddy
my mom he's scared of me getting killed
due to the country's current state and
terrorists my mom took a few days to
research all the negative things
unemployment bankruptcy etc about Greece
to try to dissuade me from going well if
she looked up the [ __ ] is it Santa
Rio Santa rally what the [ __ ] Frank
Santa relates to comedian what's that
[ __ ] beautiful place you stay it's
all everyo all the buildings are white
is right on the Mediterranean Sea if she
looked that up she'd be fine listen if
you live in America and you just sit in
you know if you're gonna listen to
international news they're not gonna
talk to you about great [ __ ] you got to
watch the Travel Channel if they're
gonna show the news all you're gonna
hear is bad [ __ ] that's like everybody
and for everybody in England thinks
everybody like over here weighs 400
pounds and owns 15 guns and you walk
down the street up with them on your hip
you know what I mean I see just as many
fat [ __ ] in in [ __ ] Great Britain
maybe not as much but there's a lot of
fish and chip eating [ __ ] rotted
teeth
dirty dirty white people out there but
that's all that's all you're gonna know
tell her to put on the Travel Channel
send her a couple of [ __ ] links all
right anyways he goes I understand that
she's worried about her son but I'm also
aware that she
Michelle and she's never traveled abroad
after hearing on the podcast that you
have been to Greece recently no I
haven't I want to go there I went to
Italy recently my question for you is do
you think an average Joe first-time
parenthesis nervous travel like myself
will feel safe any words to put me at
ease I would love to hear what you have
to say good or bad as this will help in
my decision dude the greatest [ __ ]
thing is you're going with your
girlfriend and she's a seasoned traveler
she'll know what the [ __ ] to do so just
follow her lead but I would encourage
you to step out of your shell learn a
couple of phrases the locals love when
you make an attempt to speak their
language even in Paris as much as they
get [ __ ] if you're really [ __ ] trying
and you're showing respect for their
culture and you're on your best behavior
that's another thing too when you travel
abroad you're on your best behavior
unlike all these [ __ ] Europeans so
many of them that come over here they
literally start trashing America to you
in the United States of America it's
like Jesus Christ what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you you know I mean like as much as
like Doug was just teasing when I go
over there I'm on my best [ __ ]
behavior all right I go onstage I'll
tease them a little bit but in general I
talk about what a great [ __ ] time I'm
having there you can easily pick apart
any [ __ ] place that you go to so
anyways I would learn a couple of
phrases dude you're gonna eat you're
gonna have food over there like you've
never had here before you're gonna see
things you've never had you have to swim
in the Mediterranean Sea it is [ __ ]
life-changing and dude I'm telling you
right now if you have any sort of stress
in your life if you stay along the
Mediterranean from Spain all the way
over to Greece like you can't [ __ ]
miss you know just all I would say is
just watch out for pickpockets okay
those gypsies are the [ __ ] Bill
Belichick and Tom Brady's of
pickpocketing I mean they it is a
[ __ ] art form they're so good at it
you almost won't be mad like how the
[ __ ] did they do that all right so
that's the biggest thing that I would
worry about and especially watch your
wife
with their big stupid [ __ ] purses and
they're all excited and they're [ __ ]
looking around this is what you do
alright you make a copy of your passport
okay
copy you [ __ ] passport and you
[ __ ] keep you you know have it in the
safe at the [ __ ] hotel alright keep
it at the hotel
I take my chances with some cleaning
lady taking your passport she ain't
gonna [ __ ] do that right you have a
copy of that alright I would definitely
wear some sort of [ __ ] like pants
that have zippers on them that you can
zip that [ __ ] shut and when a bunch of
people start coming up to you crowding
you be it on the subway or anything like
that you put your hand on your [ __ ]
wallet you have it right there I
wouldn't have don't have any [ __ ]
thing of value whatsoever and I'm
telling you right now this probably
making you [ __ ] nervous or whatever
this is just this is just you know
misdemeanour stealing [ __ ] what will
make your life [ __ ] miserable because
you're gonna have your credit cards and
all that type of [ __ ] and your money and
all of that it's just you know
pickpockets is the only [ __ ] thing
that I ran into when I was over there
that's the only thing you have to worry
about and just really really be super
[ __ ] hyper [ __ ] aware when you're
walking up to whatever the [ __ ] tourists
eat then what are they got over there
they have the ruins all of that [ __ ] you
know you're gonna go any of that type of
stuff like in Paris if you go up to the
Eiffel Tower you have your hands on your
[ __ ] and when people come walking up to
you
speaking in English just literally just
[ __ ] go no hablo no hablo and just
[ __ ] and if they keep coming at you
just say get the [ __ ] away from me I'm
telling you right now you just tell them
to get the [ __ ] away from you any of
those [ __ ] broads coming up to you
they want to you know you're at the
Eifel out yeah I feel tower what are you
gonna you stand in line you go in the
Eiffel Tower get the [ __ ] away from me
they're coming up there to steal from
you watch out for their kids that's the
only [ __ ] thing because they have
[ __ ] tremendous at it that's all at
any time you walk out of there and I
would also the next advice I'd give you
is
like just bring carry on I'd even say
that to your wife to just bring your
girlfriend just bring carry on
you're gonna weigh the same [ __ ]
t-shirt and shorts basically every
goddamn day no one's gonna give a [ __ ]
you're on vacation flip-flops and all of
that type of [ __ ] okay all I can say is
just like you know under pack and if you
want to buy if you want to buy like some
touristy [ __ ] you know I love I love
magnets I love those patches those flags
that you're gonna sew onto a coat or
some [ __ ] you know you have the memories
you have the pictures you what are gonna
Union you don't you go out and buy some
wooden shoes and a big beer stein if you
want to buy some [ __ ] like that ship it
back do that just go they have a good
time watch your [ __ ] valuables when
you're around [ __ ] if you're on the
subway and if you're near anything
touristy other than that have a great
[ __ ] time
chill out eat the best [ __ ] food
you're ever gonna [ __ ] have and swim
in the Mediterranean Sea
and you'll have those memories for your
whole [ __ ] life it's the greatest
[ __ ] thing and I feel bad for your
mom that she's never traveled outside of
the country cuz it's a great thing all
right clingy girlfriend clingy
girlfriend bump bump bump a bump hey
Bill as you may have read from the title
of this email I am dealing with a clingy
girlfriend we've been dating for three
months now and pretty much have only
known each other what we've been dating
for three months now and pretty much
have only known each other for three
months now so it's a pretty new
relationship okay so I get to even work
with her gradually work up the balls you
saw and you said [ __ ] she coming with
me and she was like oh my god he's so
direct anyways as I've gotten deeper in
the relationship I've started to notice
more and more red flags I'll tell you
this right now if you start noticing
more and more red flags three months in
I'm are I already have my finger on the
[ __ ] eject button personally this far
into your email okay for for example she
gets mad and starts crying if I want to
go to the gym by myself and not bring
her up [ __ ] this over over and over over
[ __ ] over
or if I don't reply to her text within
five minutes she calls me and asked me
why I haven't answered
she's even already said I love you to me
and I actually said it back when we were
having sex accidentally said I love you
only a guy can say that and now she says
it back to me all the time and I haven't
and I have to say it back because I
don't want to break her heart and tell
her that I don't feel the same way well
you already have you already have all
right just give her a three month broken
heart get out - get out I've even tried
to break up with her like a week ago get
out get out and she started to have a
breakdown saying how much she needed me
and how she can't live with that get out
get out get out of here so I told her
that we could just stayed together
because I felt that all right dude
you've basically already broken up with
her she goes she also just randomly flat
out said that she can see us together
forever I don't know why I'm noticing
all these things now but I'm only 19
years of age well there you go dude to
be honest I still sorry the [ __ ] is
going off my throat here screen too much
just say and to be honest I still want
to live the bachelor lifestyle and not
be in relation to you know while they
were answers to your question try all
the different fish in the sea
sorry if I sound douchey but I just
really need help here but I don't know
what to do thanks Bill and come back -
I'm not mean say the name of the state
this chicks such a psycho yeah dude this
is what I would do and I'm taking this
from al Madrigal the great al Madrigal
who no one knows how to end [ __ ] like
him if he listened to any of our live
ATC podcast he worked in his family
business and at your age 19 he was
already he was the hatchet man he fired
adults and he told me one time the best
way to get out of a relationship okay if
this is for everybody do it if you have
a woman in your life and you have to
break up with her there are gonna drag
you through the [ __ ] okay if you want to
expedite the
deplaning process if she has anything
over your apartment get it all together
put it in a box call her say We Need to
Talk
you show up with the box you handed the
box you tell her it's [ __ ] oh right
you let her cry you [ __ ] leave now if
she has keys to your place you don't
even need to ask for him back you
already have changed the locks if she
offers to give you the keys back you
take them but you never offer the
information that you have changed the
[ __ ] locks it's out it's over it's
done dude rip this band-aid off
that's your [ __ ] Christmas gift and
anybody out there right now male or
female if you're in relationship you
don't want to be in [ __ ] do it do it
[ __ ] tonight get your box together
change your [ __ ] locks end the [ __ ]
your Christmas gift don't go to another
[ __ ] family event someone else's
family that you don't want to [ __ ] be
with you all to yourself get the [ __ ]
out of it all right
messy girlfriend hey Billy oh I live
with my girlfriend for the past few
years and have tried and failed
repeatedly repeatedly to get her to tidy
up after herself she lives like a
borderline slob with piles of her [ __ ]
everywhere on most available surfaces
instead of putting stuff away after
herself should just leave it out for
days most days I'll come back from work
and the bed will be piled high with
clothes and the dumped contents of
handbags etc in the in the evening very
underrated the Zeppelin song by the way
this will be off this will often just
get moved to the sofa and then in the
morning move back to the bed every cover
and drawer is piled full of her [ __ ] I
have a couple of small spaces for my
belongings everywhere else is full of
clothes she hasn't worn for months
parentheses question mark years dozens
of handbags purchased she doesn't
purchase she doesn't use bits of paper
cards she keeps she's keeping for who
knows what
dozens of beauty products you get the
picture I do try to keep things tidy at
best I can for my own sanity
but would be nice to have not not to
have to nag our every so often to just
tidy up after herself I keep I if I kept
pissing on the toilet seat and she kept
telling me how annoying it was I think
she'd be right in thinking what the what
the hell is wrong with this dude
surely tidying up after yourself is
about respect for the other person or
people you live with I know the hope
accept me for who I am [ __ ] and all
and all that but come on I was wondering
what your you were the lovely Nia's Lee
knows thoughts on this hour well I'll
tell you this too that's not gonna get
any better and she sound like you got a
small-time hoarder on your lot on your
hands here forget about if you get
married and have kids so you got it you
gotta ask yourself right now are you
gonna marry this person if you're not
pack up your own box and get the [ __ ]
out of there and already have an
apartment ready to go by the way you
pack up your box you bring the [ __ ] over
to the [ __ ] apartment while she's at
work then you call her you say listen we
need to talk and then you get the [ __ ]
out of there you say I'm going for a
drive you drive over to your new
apartment and then you call her up from
a payphone and you say by the way when I
said I was going for a drive what I
really should have said was I just moved
out good luck to you and you know let's
let's try and win in Chicago and you
hang up you go little Robert Kennedy
there right it's [ __ ] over I can tell
you right now dude I couldn't tolerate
that I couldn't tolerate living with the
[ __ ] slob
there's no I [ __ ] hated that when I
lived when I had guy roommates I was I
never understood that
like how guys thought it was funny to
have like [ __ ] pizza boxes and all
there's like living like a [ __ ]
animal it's like guys we live here it's
[ __ ] gross so you have to decide if
you love this person enough to accept
this part of them or you have to or
maybe you throw down an ultimatum like
if there's no [ __ ] way I'm living my
life like this
this is completely unacceptable you have
way too much [ __ ] you need to throw out
at least seven
percent of your [ __ ] okay and if she
gives you a rough time and just say
listen you either that [ __ ] is going out
the door or I am are you saying that
you're choosing that over me yes yes
because I'm telling you right now I am
NOT going to be happy are you telling me
that you love your [ __ ] bags more
than you love me
just turn that stupid psych psychology
[ __ ] right back on them get it the [ __ ]
out of here
it gets the [ __ ] out or I get the [ __ ]
out and then you put on some Christmas
music all right here we go next one
Three Stooges
hello mr. Breuer I was wondering who
your fate were who is your favorite
stooge I know most people are curly fans
but I've always been a Shemp fan anywho
have a good day
Shemp is unbelievably underrated the
fact that he had to follow curly and
curly was in bad health slash I think
might have died during his tenure I
loved Shemp
but curly yeah curly is the best but
Larry Larry's under [ __ ] and rated -
Larry's [ __ ] hilarious and Moe is the
bully I could never get into Moe cuz I
had an older brother I was just like
that [ __ ] [ __ ]
I used to love it every once in a while
when Moe would loose one of those little
slap battles but um I loved all of them
and people always say you know you're
either a Stooges fan or you like the
Marx Brothers
I [ __ ] hated the Marx Brothers I
thought they were boring as [ __ ] I bet
if I got a funk now that I'm older maybe
I'd enjoy it more but uh I don't know I
just thought it was clever [ __ ] where
Three Stooges was just [ __ ] it was
hilarious they were just beating the
[ __ ] out of each other and I don't know
it's clever as a joke is is there
anything funnier than seeing somebody
walking into a [ __ ] window of falling
down a flight of stairs there's nothing
funnier than watching somebody hurt
themselves I don't know maybe I'm just
maybe I'm just not smart enough you know
what I should look at the Marx Brothers
before II trash them I will tell you
that one guy could [ __ ] play the harp
like nobody huh
MVM event let's do a little advertising
then I'll wrap up the podcast MVM tea
watches movement watches we get it
holiday shopping can be tough but thanks
to movement watches all that gift-giving
anxiety can disappear with the press of
a button these watches make the perfect
purchase for just about anyone in your
life guy or girl remember these watches
start at only 95 bucks all right what at
where am I the holiday shopping season
is here with moving watches you can skip
the crop that we just [ __ ] set this
[ __ ] will we watch the start of just $95
at a department store and you're looking
at at a department so be looking at four
to five hundred bucks for these watches
over 500 thousands of these watches have
been sold in over a hundred sixty
countries get 15% off today with free
shipping free returns by going to
movement watches calm / / this watch has
a really clean design seriously you'll
be getting compliments everywhere you go
when you put it on and it's only 95
bucks now is the time to step up your
watch game go-to movement watches calm /
/ join the movement and lastly but not
leastly stamps calm and everybody with
the holidays almost here you don't have
time to go to the post office you don't
have time anyways especially during the
holiday season the line is gonna be out
the [ __ ] door it will be packed with
everyone mailing holiday gifts and
packages so do what I do use stamps calm
instead with stamps calm you could avoid
all the season now all the hassles of
the season man going to the post office
during the builds busy holidays right
then the mailman tall pale man comes by
picks it up I use stamps calm to send
out all my posters and all of that [ __ ]
and my gifts [ __ ] it I'll try that this
year trust me if I could do it you can't
- it's that easy right now I can get you
a better offer from stamps comm than
what's on their homepage sign up for
stamps com use my last name bird to get
a four week trial plus it's one hundred
and ten dollar bonus offer that includes
postage and a digital scale scale go to
Stan's com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in bur that stamps
comm enter birth alright that is the
podcast for this week I hope you guys
enjoyed it it's been a brutal
for me you know I'm very happy that we
were able to find a new poem for my dog
they've already sent his texts in
pictures and she's totally fine and his
you know I'm glad that we didn't have to
you know I was there was no [ __ ] way
any that that dog was not gonna continue
on living she's had an amazing life
she's lived like three different books
and me and my wife were happy to be what
we do seven and a half years with her
and I love her to death I'm gonna miss
her like hell but I had to do it because
you know the alternative was gonna be
something horrible and I did not want to
have to [ __ ] live through that but I
am devastated and I would appreciate it
if you don't send me any [ __ ]
insensitive tweets about it
because I'm really on the ropes right
here all right
that's the podcast go [ __ ] yourselves
and check in on you on Thursday